>> Tucker: POLICE DEPARTMENT
ACROSS AMERICA ARE BEING
DEFUNDED AS VIOLENT CRIME IS
HITTING RECORD LEVELS.
WHAT DO YOU DO IN RESPONSE?
WE MADE A DOCUMENTARY ON THIS
QUESTION ON TUCKER CARLSON
ORIGINALS AND LOOKED AT HOW
PEOPLE SURVIVED WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT REFUSED TO PROTECT
THEM.
IN L.A. WE TALKED TO KOREANS WHO
DEFENDED THEIR PROPERTY DURING
THE 1992 RACE RIOTS WHEN THEY
WERE TARGETED.
HERE IS A CLIP FROM THAT.
>> WE HEARD A GUNSHOT.
>> DAVID WAS IN KOREA TOWN WHEN
THE RIOTS BROKE DOWN.
>> IT WAS APRIL 29, 1992.
I WOULD STAY IN MY STORE.
>> THE KOREAN COMMUNITY WAS HARD
HIT BY THE RIOTING.
MANY INNER CITY STORES ARE
KOREAN OWNED.
>> WE ARE ON OUR OWN.
NO OPTION WE HAVE TO DEFEND OUR
STORE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHAT STORE
OWNERS DID.
>> I ONLY HAVE ONE THING IN MY
MIND.
PROTECT OUR KOREAN PEOPLE.
>> [GUNFIRE].
>> Tucker: THOSE GUYS WERE
REALLY TOUGH AND REALLY BRAVE
AND AN INSPIRATION TO ALL OF US.
THE DOCUMENTARY IS CALLED
SURVIVING DISORDER.
IT'S ON FOX NEWS